THOUGH.
WAS A 4-3 LOSS GAVE IT
BACK.
>> Butch: ARE YOU PAYING
ATTENTION.
FOR - -
MAKAR, TO THE LEFT SIDE FOR
GIRARD.
HIS PASS.
OFF NELSON'S ST TOWARDS THE BLUE
LINE.
THERERFOUR ON FOUR.
DEVON TOEWS.
-- HIGH
WHY NOT GIVE IT
CROSS-CHECKING CALL.
>> Butch: THAT'S NOT A GOOD WAY
CLUTTERBUCK AND PULOCK.
TWO ON TWO WITH TREE.THE DOORST.
MAKAR WITH THE STEAL THE OTHER
ALL ABOUT VARLAMOV AS THE
ISLANDERS COLS WIDE.
>> Butch: THIS LINE'S BEEN GOOD
FOR THE
AND THEY SCORE.
AFTER ALL OF WORK.
MAKAR TAKING A LOOK.
SLIDES IT ALL THE WAY ACROSS.
POINTS IN 56-GAME THROW IT OUT N
A HURRY.
RANTANEN TO THE FRONT OF THE
NET.NET, THEY HANG ON TO
THE LOOSE PUCK.PASS IN FRONT.
DEVON TOEWS ALL ALONE, HE
SCORES. AN IDEA WHAT'S GOING
ON OUT FRONT.
10th OVERALL PICK.
BACK DOORERS STICKY AT THE BLUE
LINE ABLE TO KEEP THE PUCK IN.
BOUNCED PAST KADRI, DIDN'T KNOW
WHERE IT WAS, PALMIERI
OFF THE BAR
ANDD TO THE
NET.
GOT TO GET THE CAMERA THERE
QUICK ENOUGH.
>> Brendan:INUTES OF
THE THIRD PERIOD.
BEAUVILLIER.
TO PULOCK.
OVER TO PEPE
DOBSON.
PENALTY UPCOMING AGAINST
COLORADO.
SEBASTIAN AHO.
OFFSIDE. THE WALL FOR
BAILEY.
DOBSON.
26.2 LEFT.
IT'S A ONE-GOAL
21st OF THE YEAR.
>> Butch: GOT